bonsoir à vous deux on va commencer avec
monsieur je n'ai monsieur jeunes et
qu'est ce que ça représente cette
annonce pour votre communauté
aujourd'hui c'est un grand soulagement
on y travaille et quand même plusieurs
années pour arriver à cette journée
importante pour nous
donc c'est d'abord un soulagement at il
ajouté c'est vraiment une grande fierté
est capable d'annoncer aujourd'hui puis
il voir un peu à part c'est la semaine
prochaine les travaux commencés nous
pour la réalisation de ce projet est-ce
que ça a été des négociations difficiles
parce que l'on est à 6 cents le
kilowattheure on dit que c'est le projet
le moins cher de tous les parcs éoliens
au québec
est ce à dire que les négociations ont
été ardues avec hydro-québec et avec le
gouvernement du québec laquelle on met
en cause une adulte a réussi ce qui fait
que le prix est compétitif aujourd'hui
c'est les avancées technologiques et ont
eu des baisses de taux d'intérêt marqué
ce qu'ils font diminuer les coûts ont
naturellement bon pour ses congés l'eau
dans le fond le contexte économique et
technologique faire en sorte et c'est
mon cher aujourd'hui
ça fait tellement la rentabilité du
projet tel qu'on l'avait prévu en 2018
ce sera rentable on espère que ça va
être rentable
justement pour avoir les meilleurs quand
on fait passer pour les communautés ni
mais dans vos projections c'est rentable
de l'année 1 c'est rentable et trente
années comment vous voyez les choses
dans nos prévisions on est accompagné de
semaine et d'expérience du côté des nous
pour continuer avec cet homme oui c'est
rentable dès la première demie et on
sait que le reims est variable mais des
moyennes annuelles intéressante est
significative pour les communautés
est ce que vous attendez ce que les 300
emplois en construction les dix emplois
permanents suite soit occupé par des i
nous le patron de boralex a dit qu'il y
avait des objectifs mais sans les
données de façon précise et pâtit
donner des chiffres comme les ans une
politique pour maximiser les retombées
économiques dans les gens la côte nord
principalement chez les inouïes et les
entrepreneurs et travailleurs de la
côte-nord
donc on va travailler fort avec les
milieux des communautés innues et la
région de sept-îles et port-cartier pour
une majorité de travailleurs qui
viennent la région dans une partie d une
il y aura sûrement contre 100% de
travail réunis sur le chantier mais on
espère en avant une bonne proportion
puis il ya de la place aussi pour les
travailleurs québécois des régions d'un
quota est ce que d'autres projets qui se
pointe à l'horizon pour vous pour les
communautés innues et que ce soit avec
hydro-québec ou avec d'autres
du côté de l'énergie
on avait un peu l'ouverture de madame
mme brochu concernant les possibilités
futures en eau en énergie éolienne ils
nous regardent l'industrie éolienne et
plusieurs années on parle de 2005 donc
c'est des possibles dans le futur de
faire du projet s'en vont nous
intéresser également et c'est un premier
projet nationaux donc c'est la première
fois que notre communauté nous sont
partenaires dans un projet donc dans le
froid on espère que ça va donner le goût
ou communautique continuer à travailler
ensemble
c'est clairement un jour historique
monsieur j'avais merci beaucoup sa
treizième si on continue maintenant avec
sophie brochu pdg d'hydro-québec
madame brosseau spc pour vous le début
d'une offensive d'hydro-québec dans
l'énergie éolienne
je vous en parle pas de l'amour de sa
vie
hydro québec d'accueillir jérôme de
l'ofii depuis plusieurs années ce qu'on
annonce aujourd'hui c'est un projet qui
est acheté par hydro québec production
il faut savoir que ce n'est pas un
projet qui s'en va dans le parc dont les
coûts seront assumés par la clientèle au
québec hydro québec est un grand
producteur d'hydroélectricité et puis
aujourd'hui ce qu'on fait de plus en
plus c'est qu'on y ajoute des moyens de
production un peu plus agile peu plus
rapide à mettre en production
ce n'est pas en contradiction d'être
l'hydroélectricité argentin j'entends
certains médias qui disent qu'on oppose
les deux pas du tout ce qui est beau
aujourd'hui c'est de pouvoir bénéficier
de tout seul
enfin l'hydroélectrique là lorsqu'on
fait c'est qu'on développe notre
portefeuille plus avant dans d'autres
moyens de production électrique
donc ce n'est pas de contradiction
contrainte c'est une image
complémentarité on est chanceux on a les
deux et oui il va y avoir plus de
projets éoliens qui vont se développer
au québec justement pour être en prob
les mentalités nos actifs existants
le message ce matin c'était l'éolien
certainement c'était l'entente avec les
i nous mais c'était aussi de dire on
n'est pas sur les barrages
hydroélectriques les grands projets
qu'avait monsieur legault là on n'est
pas là tu ce n'est pas sur la table à
court et moyen terme
il a tout à fait raison en fait hydro
québec
quand on fait nos exercices de ce qu'on
appelle bilan énergie puissance on
pondère tous les outils de production à
notre disposition aujourd'hui
l'estimation que l'on fait de la demande
sur les vingt trente quarante prochaines
années
ici sur les marchés limitrophes au
canada et aux états unis et on regarde
quels sont les moyens de production dont
nous aurons besoin
et aujourd'hui comme le 10e prix
ménisque en hydro québec regarde son
futur à court et moyen terme dans un
horizon prévisible on ne voit pas la
nécessité de relancer d'autres grands
ouvrages hydroélectriques
cela dit on ya la nécessité de produire
plus parce que il ya le projet du
massachusetts
le projet de l'état de new york
potentiel donc on va voir là en terme de
production 9,45 térawattheures dès 2022
8 térawatts heure vers new york si ça
marche avec new york dès 2024
puis toute une série de projets en
réalisation ou qui sont possibles des
véhicules électriques gnl québec des
centres de données des producteurs
autrement dit les surplus vont
s'évanouir l'a complètement dans les
prochaines années
ouais mais moi je maintenais ça des
surplus vous le savez la surplus c'est
quelque chose qui vaut prochaine
c'est en restant table ce qu'on avait
c'était des capacités la tente qui
attendaient d'être utilisé c'est comme
un repos qui attendaient pour être servi
et il est normal que ce soit comme ça
alors imaginez vous la que là
responsabilité première d'hydro-québec
c'est d'approvisionner ses marchés et de
le faire en temps réel c'est comme si on
devait voler un avion entre par exemple
québec et vancouver
vous voulez pas atterrir l'avion avec un
demi-litre de jet fuel la soute un vous
voulez avoir suffisamment de carburant
pour vous rendre l'eau vous aurez à vous
rendre
c'est la même chose quand on planifie
les approvisionnements d'hydro-québec et
oui il ya plusieurs projets il ne se
réaliseront pas touche pas tous en même
temps il ya une trajectoire qui est de
plus en plus incertaine aux fins de ce
qu'on avance dans ta mais chose certaine
c'est que la mouvance socio économique
et environnemental aujourd'hui est
extrêmement porteuses c'est ce qui nous
permet de voir que les va pas que nous
avions à servir et d'énergie disponibles
dont nous disposions va être valorisés
et c'est pour ça que aujourd'hui c'est
extraordinaire
la plus grande nouvelle lors c'est la
nouvelle de la réalisation d'appui 8 et
d'un projet anti drew québec une
communauté autochtone qui va bâtir sur
son territoire traditionnel sur son état
civil
1 un projet économe et énergétiques au
bénéfice de la communauté
une attente qui est intelligente pour
tous que c'est extrêmement porteur donc
ce n'est que du bon aujourd'hui que nous
avons a annoncé et c'est une première et
j'espère une première d'une longue série
de partenariats avec les communautés
dans le passé les projets éoliens ont eu
un impact à la hausse sur les tarifs
d'électricité qu'en sera-t-il avec ce
projet
ce projet ne sera pas supporté par la
clientèle québécoise race et hydro
québec production qui le met dans son
parc de production le distributeur qui
hydro québec distribution doit déposer
la régie de manière récurrente ce qu'on
appelle un plan d'approvisionnement où
il dépose au cours des 10 15 20
prochaines années sont des dimensions
évolution de la demande pas de nom
d'intérêts pas de rôle absolument pas au
bio le projet a put n'a aucune incidence
à la roue sur les tarifs des clients
d'hydro-québec dans ce si important le
comprend on l'a compris ma david rocher
merci rocco au plaisir au revoir marque